on regarde tout de suite votre première
phrase dans l'émission très très content
qui rejoint une équipe de touche pas à
mon poste applaudissements pour jean luc
lemoine et voilà petit truc déjà pour
vous jean luc lemoine était mon ex on
est sortis ensemble de 86 à 88
voilà il faut que les gens le savent
c'est très bien de tout balancer tout de
suite un peu de mystère
bonjour lui on a fait une petite pub de
jean luc lemoine sur france 4
regardez on luc lemoine est avec nous
actuellement je suis dans touche pas à
mon poste est-ce que j'ai retrouvé un
vrai boulot j'enlève vous soutenez qui
m'ont moi j'étais pour johnny malouf
dégoûté mais pour le talent pour le non
bon j'ai tout pour tous j'ai envie de
chialer puisque pour m'insulter moi mais
surtout avec the truth juste un petit
coucou à justine et je trouve que c'est
très élégante de pas verdict avait une
gastro
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors je lui on a plein de films hors
films de jean-luc regarder et et
jean-luc regarder bonjour les gars les
fatiguer les mieux mieux de mieux en
mieux de bien rapaille a bu un sondage à
l'époque quand il était dans on a tout
essayé
non on n'est pas couché on n'est pas
couché et il avait fait un sondage pour
savoir qui était le chroniqueur le plus
beau gosse de la télé et c'est jean-luc
avaient péri dans l'est la vérité
jean-luc j'étais arrivé premier mon ami
cyril hanouna
c est foutu de ma gueule parce qu'il
comprenait pas le délire il faut savoir
que le numéro 2 c'était nicolas
canteloup ouais bon je pense que se
savait rien à voir et que le physique
oui parce que non mais j'ai très beau
nous voulons ainsi si bas tu veux tu
peux pas me dire ça bah ça dure ça me
fait rêver une fois que je passe à
chaque fois c'est un ascenseur
l'ascenseur émotionnel de dégueulasse à
correct je t'ai jamais trouvé
dégueulasse sinon aujourd'hui je peux
juste pourquoi pourquoi vous rappeler
toujours cette anecdote du fait que
j'avais été plus beaux gosses des
chroniqueurs même si c'était une
surprise
pas du tout on rappeler juste qu'il est
beau gosse et si on refaisait aa
sondages ce serait encore lui isabelle
aux panneaux on a fait un pas longtemps
moi je suis tombé sexy et dès le début
ah ouais il est très beau oui